you've probably seen these fun colorful
tasty fish cakes in your ramen bowls or
udon and soba noodle dishes
they're called fish cakes and these
little side pieces have a long and
powerful history in japan
[Music]
fish cakes have existed in japanese
cuisine since the 8th century
over the years various kinds of fish
cakes have been developed but there is
one kind of fish cake that has stood the
test of time
it's called hen pen
often made from a fish meat called
pollock these fluffy white fish cakes
are considered the ogs of fish cakes and
some of the best hand pens are made here
by this guy
a legendary fish cake shop that's been
selling and making hen pen since 1688
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
may not be as colorful as its fish cake
counterparts but people love it
these fish cakes are in such demand
during peak season that toshio produces
about four thousand handpins in a day
[Music]
hamper
surprisingly after four decades toshio
has not grown tired of making handpins
because for him it's more than just a
job
musical
[Music]